- So you've been at 30 Rock
forever now, I feel like.
- Yeah,
- Yeah, no matter the job.
So, so do you get along
with everybody in the
building or is there like
one guy that's like, oh,
every time you walk in?
- No, I've been there for 25 years now.
Isn't that crazy?
- [Kelly] That. Wow.
(audience cheers)
- At NBC going in the same
elevators. It's bizarre.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I know everyone there.
At one point I used to have
like keys to different offices
and stuff because Dan
Akeroyd came to the show
and was so nice to me.
And he was like, "So you're the new kid?"
I go, "Yeah." He goes,
"Hey, Jimmy, come with me.
I'll go show you this spot."
He goes, "I used to hang out
with all the security guards,"
and he goes, "Me and Belushi
would come down to this area."
And we crawled, we broke into an office.
This is serious. Crawl through a window.
And we went out and the outdoor was this
giant beautiful lawn, like a patio.
That's just like on the 11th floor.
And we went out and it's
just a gorgeous place.
It was like an old, like back
in the day they used to have
Tuscanini, his office, but
him and Belushi and Akeroyd
would go and-
- Just get high up there?
- [Jimmy] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Thank you for saying that.
I wasn't going to say it.
I was trying to think how to say it.
- I have a security meeting.
- Maybe we were going to read books.
- Have a security meeting and
make sure everything is good.
- (laughs) Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's what we would call it.
- So were friends with
all the security guys.
So we would go around,
just break into stuff,
and just have fun.
- I love how he's like,
"Oh, you're the new guy.
Let me show you to break
and enter." (laughter)
- Like, that's amazing.